[Music]
in why you lyin news Waialae submitted
by a baby shark a man is suing Burger
King after they backed out of giving him
free food for life
Wow Dawg why well if you eat Burger King
you're gonna die soon anyway in his life
expectancy and so now he's suing about
$9,000 which is the exact amount he and
his lawyer say would cost it would cost
for him to get a whopper meal a week for
the rest of his life cuz he's 50 years
old they estimate they owe
73 that's morbid as [ __ ] why would they
vez why would they tell him that wait he
doesn't want to take the free whoppers
for life no why no no that's not what it
is is it so he got his free whoppers for
life cancel wait no I know what it is
he's suing Burger King because he's
gonna he's dying from eating the burgers
lost his life time oh he loves food
thing I bet you how do you get a free
lifetime Burger King Awards situation
welcome to JK news all right so this man
in organ he his name is Curtis he says
that he was accidentally locked into the
bathroom of this particular Burger King
when the employees tried to get him out
they gave him a flyswatter to try to get
out but then he ended up cutting his
hand with a flyswatter bathroom door
would not open yeah I'm so confused
right now
wait why give them all they're trying to
get him to Jimmy the door with the door
open and then later on there's like the
sign saying that the bathroom doesn't
work or the men's bathroom and so he was
saying that he could hear like the
employees laughing behind the door I
mean it's hard not to laugh though right
they ended up saying like hey you know
what we're sorry for everything you went
through because then a locksmith finally
showed up and got him out why was that
not the first thing he know right the
first thing was the flyswatter [ __ ]
this was only like over an hour it
wasn't super long that's pretty long I
mean like hours and hours you know that
could've been longer
but anyway so then they were saying that
the Burger King employees offered him a
lifetime supply of Bertram meals at no
cost and so that whenever he would
return to that restaurant the employees
did honor the commitment for a while and
then that's when all of a sudden they
were just like nope so they offered it
to him without going through corporate
yes and without it was that location
yeah and then without even signing like
there was like no legal enforcement
agreement here either and so but he does
have two receipts that show proof that
they comped his meals
oh smart man for keeping that it was by
accident now it's crumpled up me to like
an underwear or something yeah why would
they just all of a sudden say I don't
want to do a little more what if he went
like three times a day and they're like
[ __ ] annoying guys here but you still
make a lot of money
yeah man a whopper doesn't cost much
yeah they can give away a couple
sandwiches people's don't go there
though I hate how dare you not see
delicious gourmet my house and I avoid
it at all cause what bro
I'd rather eat it than get anything else
like sex or nothing like everything else
you're not telling the truth yeah you
like living men McDonald
[Laughter]
I'm still confused so can I just Greek
regroup let's regroup and I'm gonna tell
you what I think the situation is quick
quick synopsis quick quick
dummy guy gets stuck in bathroom okay
take too long to rescue him in the
meantime they're laughing what does he
just poop do to make up for their
mistakes developing in free lifetime
burgers
oh shoot their minds so this is what
happened I get it so the guy was gonna
sue corporate right
but the employees got scared like no
don't do that we'll just give you free
burgers for life before you can sue them
before they can sue then then you know
time went by and then they're like I
think it'd be a lot of time has passed
where you can't sue us anymore so now
you don't get free burgers after that
statute of limitations yeah have you
guys ever been stuck in a small space
though for longer than 10 minutes thank
God thank God I would die on like a
allegience flight like three hours or
spirit life yes I was stuck in a couch
my brother put me in there a couch you
know the couch you could take it's like
you could take out a bed pull that couch
pullout bed put me under there cuz when
I was a little kid if there's a big hole
you could put me under there and he sat
on top of it and I was stuck like a
[ __ ] are you crying what about
what about you I was in Kaiser to see my
dermatologist and I got stuck in an
elevator and I scream bloody murder and
they were like we're coming it's only
been two minutes but I was screaming did
you hit the emergency so I hit
everything but people knew you were in
there oh yeah oh they did fine I thought
you were stuck in nobody knew an hour
seems like a lifetime when you're stuck
somewhere and you're somebody anxious
like me or my your head just gets to you
there are steps the first thing you have
to do you have to designate a pee corner
that's the person you know there is a
thing on the elevator where it's like
you could ask for help and then you can
you talk to someone yeah yeah there's
someone that answers
yeah yourself in the elevator mm-hmm you
didn't try removing one of those tiles
and in a climb out no no you should
never do that because when I was at Cal
State Long Beach somebody died on to the
person and Cal State Long Beach is a
really horrible story was stuck in
between two floors and she tried to
climb out but the elevator kicked in I
used she got crushed and I was across
the building and apparently it was the
most gruesome was like traumatising
sound you could hear oh I got stuck once
you know the chicken that the Chinese
yeah but I deal with my friend Gary
where our penises and our Peters Augusto
oh that's hot yeah we start pulling it
started stretching their penises out so
then we had to touch the tip together so
that was weird
how long do you figure that up that's
pretty six hours if you touch penis tips
like that though
is that gay no no no no I've done it
like 20 times with different of guys
it's not gay it's not gay at all or
fighting in court fighting yeah yeah um
guard yeah
[Applause]
good yeah so he's asking for over $9,000
but they're saying the lawyers are
saying like there's no legal agreement
here so I think it's just [ __ ] up that
they stopped feeding them what they
promised that it was it just one meal a
day or how many meals a day it was a
meal um not a day a week one meal a week
that's it maybe right but how
traumatising is being stuck in a
bathroom well depends if it's like an
email would or something those [ __ ]
bathrooms are disgusting dude there's
caca all over I guess you're right dude
yes smells in there yeah but you know
it's like you know there are worse
places
you know ours not bad you're not an
elevator that can fall straight down
during your stationary I think the last
straw was when he sliced his hand with
the flyswatter the last straw cuz they
gave my flyswatter you don't know that
maybe he purposely did that how long was
he in there for over an hour Joe God
listen do it we've said it over an hour
like nine times wrong those glasses are
[ __ ] you up dude
over and out I think he's just
overreacting then look at the bug's life
do I make the glasses off I don't think
he whole lifetime full of food I mean
people are sensitive now like it's not
fair that they're laughing at him
you could have been patty what if he
suffers a panic attack
it's probably from the left in when
people were laughing and that's what
they were worried about it being soon
packing up and they obviously it was a
joke cause I hate take your stuff up
with a flyswatter
that's pretty funny yeah I'd be so
embarrassed though well then yeah so is
this guy that's why I'd be embarrassed a
suit that I got my feelings hurt because
someone laughed at me yeah
money out of it though yeah really they
say 1 million dollars for your pain and
suffering you're gonna be like no rather
no no this is why I'm like I'd rather
suck a dick off and [ __ ] drink the
come because that's honorable
that's horrible it's true but wall it's
honorable they're very honorable that's
honorable getting laughed at and telling
on them and then making money you know
Ratbat is [ __ ] off yeah you ain't no
rat I have morals you're a principled
man and I draw the line when it comes to
things like scamming Burger King I don't
like taking advantage of a situation
like even if I order a hamburger and
they forget to put the meat in I don't
say I'll get it oh I've cut up if I've
been to McDonald's and I ordered a
hamburger I've opened it up and there's
cheese no meat it's not I'll just eat
the bread and cheese no it's so true we
are so spineless we're smiling Macanudo
really crappy restaurant and services
[ __ ] is if everything is [ __ ] and they
ask us hey how's the food like oh so
good you don't tell them we never let
them know this cuz you're not white only
white people do that that's very good
what about a nice restaurant and you
order fish and the steak comes out I
don't say anything
we don't say ok thank you well that's a
little different this is delicious
shellfish your steak is delicious
I could be in that bathroom for 15 hours
and come out and lost 90 pounds and get
infections and whatever restaurant and I
would go to the car like this
yeah yeah great reviews you're the one
saying sorry yeah inside cleaning it
with my tongue how do you get a uniform
what if they were mean to you though
and it's not a mistake what do you mean
cuz I get it if it's a mistake cuz that
happens right they bring the wrong water
or whatever it's cool but what if they
were an [ __ ] to you like directly
yeah you're example remember that tofu
place BCD yeah the guy handed our mail
from across the table he threw it
boiling
yeah boiling he he let it slide across
the table the better Oh No
and then you know we did we gave him a
big tip and a little smiley face and a
smiley face and thanks for the great
service and we won't because he knows
how he's acting are you sure yeah I
don't know if he knows that he's a bad
server I think he does he was really
grumpy and he basically through art tofu
that's where you bring in your Korean
dude what do you mean we don't Korean a
lot but we know how to curse somebody I
think yeah yeah yeah she buys nobody
even cares a kid has a peachy she's a
hungry boy Ari okay back to need always
a punter she buys a cat yeah now you
know yeah
[ __ ] home you [ __ ] hanging piece
of dog [ __ ] do you know who the [ __ ] I
am
come here sit down and have a
conversation with me they tell you got
your dingleberry yeah baby love that my
mom calls me a dog's dingleberry dude
she's a [ __ ] poet yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]